good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is scp-1155 object
class
Keter special containment procedures
scp-1155 is currently contained in a
disused parking lot adjacent to an
abandoned shopping center in the City
metropolitan area the building is to be
marked condemned and access to both it
and the carpark should be restricted by
foundation personnel posing as security
guards from the front company civilians
are to be deterred from entering the
site and supplied with standard cover
story 47 structural instability sinkhole
if they inquire as to why scp-1155 must
be kept under constant observation by
motion-tracking security cameras if
scp-1155 is observed to vanish mobile
task force pi-1 city-slickers should be
notified immediately personnel should
not routinely attempt to view scp-1155
directly observation must be conducted
remotely
this following portion has been stricken
from the official document but I'm going
to read it anyway
whatever flat surface that a CP 1155 is
currently inhabiting should be obscured
from view by any standard class 2
enclosed mobile containment unit or in
situations where this cannot be affected
in a timely fashion by obstructing it
with a vehicle storage container or
displaced rubble providing that this can
be done without damaging a 3 meter area
around scp-1155 s image this ends the
stricken portion of the document
following incident 1155 B it has been
observed that completely enclosing
scp-1155 has a tendency to haste in a
relocation event revised procedures now
recommend the evacuation of the
immediate area surrounding scp-1155 to
the minimum distance necessary to
prevent contact with the general public
unless scp-1155 manifests in a high
visibility location or anywhere where
preventing public egress is impossible
at the present time scp-1155 cannot be
permanently contained by any known means
approximately every 2 to 4 months
scp-1155 has been observed to
spontaneously relocate itself to other
urban environments moving as little as
15 meters from its current position up
to a maximum observed distance of 800
kilometers these relocation events can
also be triggered by damage to the
surface that scp-1155 adheres to
interruption of an attack any attempt to
reduce the size of scp-1155 s
confinement space to prevent visual
contact therefore the current
containment efforts are centered around
swiftly ascertaining scp-1155 s new
location and isolating it from public
view when such a relocation event occurs
mobile task force pi-1 should be
immediately deployed alongside local
assets to locate the new site as quickly
as possible
re-implement containment procedures and
detain any witnesses survivors of
attacks
be detained uninjured witnesses may be
administered class-a amnesiacs and then
released
[Music]
description a CP 1155 manifests as a
work of street art or graffiti depicting
the form of a humanoid creature with
sinewy four limbs claw-like hands and
the head and feathers of an owl
the depicted pose is variable but tends
towards a predatory stance with eyes
that appear to track the viewer anyone
viewing this image directly will
experience a compulsion to investigate
it further victims describe a nervous
fascination and a desire to move closer
this can be resisted with effort
especially if the subject is aware of
scp-1155 anomalous properties if a
subject approaches within 2 meters and
is not in the line of sight of another
person they will be subjected to a
violent attack suffering severe
lacerations dismemberment of extremities
whole or partial removal of soft body
parts and penetrating head trauma
consistent with those that would be
inflicted by a large beak and/or talons
the attack generally takes about 6
seconds to conclude upon which both
scp-1155 and the victim will vanish and
scp-1155 will reappear elsewhere in the
usual manner of a relocation event
within seven days attacks can be halted
before this event by re-establishing
line-of-sight to the victim but it is
not recommended see record of incident
1155 a attempts to track where the
victims are taken by equipping test
subjects with GPS locators have failed
based on tests and interruptions
performed at predefined intervals the
attack follows defined pattern
the victim will first be restrained and
the eyes and tongue will be removed
rapidly followed by the amputation of
the hands and feet the victim will then
be disemboweled and the intestines and
stomach removed death usually follows
due to shock or rapid exsanguination but
only if the attack is interrupted by
visual contact
the fate of victims who disappear along
with scp-1155 the conclusion of the
attack is unknown addenda incident 1155
a to surviving d-class personnel used
for attack interruption tests were given
medical treatment and kept alive in the
aftermath of the event both were
incoherent and could not adequately
communicate what had happened to them
though d89 786 whose eyes were removed
during the attack claimed to still be
able to see and provided a description
of a larder containing bodies of
previous victims of scp-1155 along with
the entity itself d89 786 escaped from
on-site quarters during a containment
breach by SCP and was pursued by local
law enforcement in nearby who were told
he was a severely disturbed patient from
a local mental hospital officer in
reports they saw the suspect walking
into an alleyway but before they can
apprehend a scream was heard and when
they rounded the corner it was found
that d89 786 had disappeared the
alleyway was a dead end with no visible
exits d 8 9 7 8 9 both eyes tongue hands
and feet removed before they attack
halted was successfully transferred to
sight
a period of rapid relocations was noted
in scp-1155 where it was observed in
several public places with a posture
that suggested hunting or tracking
behavior scp-1155 appeared for several
hours high up on the side of the
building in full view of many witnesses
who fortunately could not access it in
view of the difficulties of containment
site command made the decision to bring
d89 seven eight-nine back into the city
scp-1155 was observed to appear several
times on walls advertisement boards and
bridges along the transport vehicles
path da 979 was observed to become
increasingly agitated and hysterical
during this process EA 979 was
transferred to a remote location on the
edge of city limits placed in front of
scp-1155 whereupon visual contact was
broken scp-1155 and d89 789 disappeared
scp-1155 resumed previous pattern of
manageable relocation behavior incident
1155 B elements of mobile task force
pi-1 located scp-1155 in an abandoned
subway station after the most recent
relocation event team leader made the
decision to obscure scp-1155 with a
vending machine until more containment
resources arrived on the basis that
there were not enough task force members
on site to guarantee a secure perimeter
and local transients were known to use
the area for shelter scp-1155
immediately displaced to a nearby
children's playground causing casualties
before it could again be located
due to the highly public nature of this
location a decision was made at command
level to again provoke a displacement
event resulting in the current
containment location containment that
the current location was expensive
requiring that an entire shopping center
be acquired by the foundation and then
subsequently closed but the revised
containment procedures have resulted in
the longest time since a relocation
event to date and a final note from
doctor the last few containment
locations may point to a disturbing
trend previously as CP 1155 seemed to
have a pattern of appearing in low
traffic urban areas often abandoned
buildings or quiet under passes at risk
of anthropomorphism it appears to have
become emboldened and will now readily
appear in public spaces which makes
containment difficult over the
objections of the containment team leave
the damn thing uncovered better we lose
a few urban explorers or nosy kids every
couple of years rather than risking
having an abduct more people before we
can locate at each time a Suarez seem
that somewhere anyway okay that about
does it today thank you all for
listening and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre bishop desmond Hoskins and gaza
berry thank you all very much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you